oh it's official I mean it's always
beneficial but now we know is official
the month of January as the whole hates
us it hates us as moviegoers I now
submit to you the newest evidence to
that fact
the legend of Hercules the legend of
Hercules is a movie that looks like the
creators of that 2003 book of Mormon
movie you remember that it's like
they got together and they were like hey
let's create a Hercules movie but the
same shitty acting the same shitty props
same shitty lighting same shitty
costumes I looked into it it's actually
not that crew but I'm just saying it
looks like it and come on even if you're
Mormon you know that was terrible
in any case now we have a new Hercules
movies starring what looks like a bunch
of stunt men and a bunch of models so
you tell I hated this movie guys yes
there's not just bad it's a different
kind of Bad's the kind of bad you're
watching and you look at God and you're
like I'm sorry whatever it was I'm
whatever I did to piss you off
I'm really sorry from the opening shot I
was like alright this CGI is terrible
maybe it'll get better not the CGI is
completely horrible a couple of scenes
looked like it had sets which that was
cool among a bunch of shitty CGI and
really bad green-screen really bad
costumes like the costumes don't have
any grit to them they look like their
costumes made of material that looks
like it was purchased at whatever Joe
Blow fabric store the fight sequences
the fight sequences were obnoxious I
think every fight lasted 30 seconds just
seems longer because every time someone
got hit is slow-mo what happens like
look how stylistic we are it's not 2000
anymore no one gives a about that
seriously every time someone got hit it
was just kicking this llama like
and the first scene in the movie I'm
like is that gonna do this the entire
movie it does not only was everything
terrible in the entire movie set them
back no no $500 once that five hundred
dollar budget was expended once it was
gone you can tell they tried to make do
but they just couldn't I know this
because a guy got hit by a spear and he
did that tuck the spear under the arm
thing the worst part is the camera was
on the side of his body where he was
tucking the spear under his arm didn't
fake it if it's like this side he's
tucking it under his left arm but this
side no and yeah the acting sucks so I
guess we got to talk about that he
acting in this I can't finish the
sentence the villains in this movie are
so over the tire thought that dude who
played the villain an airbender was
overacting that guy is Viggo Mortensen
on Downer's compared to the guys in this
movie Hercules brother who's clearly
supposed to be Loki knockoff he just he
acts slimy all the time of me and in his
dad like Dick King with the worst fake
beard I've ever seen yells at everything
granted I'm yelling that's just because
this movie and I'm conveying a
point it's got me heated but this to II
could be ordering from Burger King and
he'll just be like I'll take a whopper
with a large order of fries and a Diet
Pepsi not a regular but diet just give
me a number one with a Diet Pepsi oh I'm
going to old on started to faint there
for a second I don't know how that guy
did that for the entire movie guys
there's not a frame I enjoyed in this
movie if it scene started to look cool
it just had bad CGI fighting in it this
movie is 'la Mortal Kombat annihilation
of Hercules movies yeah that's bad just
think about that for a second I'll let
that soak in go
yeah pretty bad right I didn't like
anything in this movie and the legend of
Hercules is
I'm officially looking forward to i
Frankenstein now I'm looking forward to
I Frankenstein I think that's why this
movie existed so a movie would look
worse than I Frank it Stein looks and
they'll be like my Frankenstein don't
look that bad in comparison let's just
watch that
all right The Legend of Hercules have
you seen it please don't I'm not gonna
ask you that new question your favorite
Greek mythology story at all anywhere
you can incorporate Wonder Woman
anything what's your favorite whatever
it is comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more